vous êtes accusé de harceler d'autres
candidats dans les anges déjà qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ça quand on vous dit
que vous avez harceler je pense que il
ya beaucoup de personnes qui se sont pas
mis de mon côté parce qu'on dit que moi
au jour d'aujourd'hui j'ai harcelé parce
que oui j'ai été sur certaines
embrouilles parce que je ne me laisse
pas faire c'est comme demain quand on
m'appelle sur une télé réalité c'est
vrai qu'on prend le personnage que je
suis ça veut dire que oui je suis
quelqu'un qui est extrêmement qui va en
fait s'exprimer sans même réfléchir et
comme n'importe quel humain sur terre en
fait je pense et il ya des à des moments
vous êtes juste naturel dans cette
émission c'est ça que vous dites je suis
à 100% naturel et c'est pour ça qu'on me
rappelle d'ailleurs et même à des mots
certains moments on m'a dit sarah arrête
parce que tu prends beaucoup trop les
choses à coeur et que ça te touchent
réellement donc on me l'a dit à
plusieurs joue son jeu vous sur
complètement
je me sens en vous même mais la façon de
vous habiller de vous tenir de 2,2 par
les jeux sans être passée complètement
autre chose
ouais vraiment important mais ces objets
extrêmement présent je suis à vous de ce
triste comme ça et parce qu'en fait
c'est qu'en faire des choses que des
gens savent pas en fait fait que est
certes moins forte en divorce on m'a
contre-attaqué sur des harcèlements
alors que vraiment pour le coup j'ai
rien à voir dedans et quand tu
t'exprimes tout le monde s'acharne sur
toi on insulte sur des lives honteux on
appuie dessus sans même savoir le
pourquoi du comment et en fait à
plusieurs reprises je vais pas vous
mentir je suis tombé même pour riblon
pas et j'ai envoyé un message à ces
personnes en leur disant en fêtard et
voir mon mode de vie je vais vous dire
car manger m'ouvrir les veines en
veulent parce que j'arrive plus j'arrive
plus à nos pommes sa gamme entendre
juste parce que j'ai un caractère qui
est assez fort donc on se dit elle peut
tout assumer sahara moi je vous dis et
même si on a eu le maillon d un peu mais
20 peut attaquer sur les raisons que ça
m'a fait rire et je vous aime beaucoup
et je vous ai un petit peu suivi vous
avez un caractère formidable moi quand
je vous ai vu dans cette émission quand
je les ai vus arriver
vous étiez tout sourire souriante et
heureuse vous
elle est loin d'être bête s'arrache pour
vous dire c'est quelqu'un voilà qui est
très sympathique et aujourd'hui moi de
vous voir pleurer je suis pas comme tout
le monde ça me désole vous avez quel âge
j'ai 28 ans vous avez 28 ans vous
magnifique vous avez l'avenir devant
vous est ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression d'avoir gâché une partie de
votre vie en faisant ça parce que je
suis sûr que peut-être que si vous aviez
pas fait les anges ou autre chose tu sûr
que vous auriez peut-être été très
heureuse dans un métier plus de l'ong où
vous ne seriez pas nous y parce que je
vous le dis vous êtes magnifique
vous êtes sympathique on se dit on a
l'impression qu'il ya des gens qui sont
brisées après ses aventures c'est pour
ça que il ya plein de gens qui veulent
arrêter ce genre d'émission parce qu'ils
ont brisé des personnes qui ont qui sont
qui sont minorés qui ont des petits sons
qui sont heureuses de vivre et
aujourd'hui avec les réseaux sociaux
parce que les réseaux sociaux et sur ses
émissions la c1 c'est un fléau
incroyable et ce qui se passe avec les
mets ce qui se passe dans danser dans
cette émission c'est vrai que l'on peut
se dire un moment on peut péter un câble
moi quand je vous entends dire la 28 ans
j'ai eu envie de m'ouvrir les veines je
peux vous dire c'est un sens et et c'est
inadmissible
et c'est pas possible d'entendre ça je
suis en fait le truc c'est que pour moi
c'est pas la télé réalité en fait c'est
l'être humain c'est l'être humain et le
sens qui veut donner à ce qu'il veut et
ce qu'il veut voir clairement quand on
parle de télé réalité oui j'ai fait le
choix d'y aller parce que oui je suis
jeune et que on propose un pays on
propose un concept je me dis je vais
aller voir
je suis parti voir je suis resté moi
même maintenant l'être humain est
mauvais partout que demain choix
caissière que je sois professeur que je
sois je me rassure c'est pas la même
exposition il y aura toujours un
il y aura toujours des gens mauvais
maintenant cette exposition je les
choisis et au jour d'aujourd'hui je ne
cracherai pas dessus parce que j'ai un
train de vie aussi qu' heureusement m'a
aidé à mettre à l'abri ma famille m'a
aidé à mettre à l'abri mois on a tous
des producers a rendu heureux de ce que
vous êtes heureuse au lot je vais vous
dire sincèrement je suis dans un concept
de vie ou au jour d'aujourd'hui je
cherche même plus à être heureuse en
fait tu cherches même si on peut dire ça
28 ans n'en paie pas ce qu'ils ont fait
je pense que la vie faut juste la vivre
et il y en a certains qui survit
d'accord et que moi je suis juste là
pour me pompe en fait combattre contre
les gens juste pour leur montrer que en
fait juste moi je suis juste moi je suis
un être humain qui dérape pas certain
moment qui peut dire des choses
pour être choquant mais moi j'ai pas le
recul de voir cette scène là le recul je
n'ai que quand je rentre chez moi et que
je regarde mon écran je me dis ah
peut-être j'aurais pas dû fonctionner
comme ça ça fait huit ans que je fais de
la télé ça fait depuis l'âge de 20 ans
que je fais de la télé donc c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui donc oui il ya des choses
que je regrette il ya des choses avec
lesquelles j'évolue
il ya des choses que je ne referai plus
il ya des choses que je ferais mais par
contre de faire de la tisza sion a line
sur mois de mars les de me faire
cyberharcèlement parce que j'ai eu un
comportement de gamine je pense pour que
n'importe qui sur terre je je vous ferai
pas ça en fait